Don't just accept the status quo.
No big challenge has ever been solved...
...and no lasting improvement has ever been achieved...
...unless people dare to try something different.
Dare to think different.
I was lucky to learn from someone who believed this deeply,...
...someone who knew that changing the world starts with following a vision,..
...not a path.
He was my friend and mentor, Steve Jobs.
It's in those truly trying moments that the fearless inspire us.
Fearless like the students of Parkland, Florida,...
...who refused to be silent about the epidemic of gun violence...
...and have rallied millions to their cause.
Fearless like the women who say #MeToo and #TimesUp,...
Women who cast light into dark places...
...and move us to a more just and equal future.
Fearless like those who fight for the rights of immigrants,...
...who understand that our only hopeful future...
...is one that embraces all who want to contribute.